great news is that you live on Sky the
mouth I don't speak English
are you German okay remember one more
hey let go
yeah great news come on from Ireland did
you think it would happen quite so
quickly
not really but we're here last night
wait and then we ain't waiting comebacks
Marlin myself my daughter please sits a
little princess yeah you get me Mike's
here today no no I think you're right I
think you're right hi you're live on Sky
exciting you yeah is exam this one say
congratulations in a real family
yeah what a princess it's fantastic news
thank you hi absolutely delighted I
think it's fantastic congratulations
wait did you have any money on it being
a girl no I'm not a gambling man so I
save my money I would have said it was a
boy right yeah I said it was a boy a lot
of great minds think alike they all feel
self-conscious that they said I don't
know are you like that sky great use
read news were you expecting the
relation of course you have to be a girl
it has to be yeah quite so quickly good
well yeah because we just came this
moment so it's just arrived away yeah I
think we'll see it today though do you
oh no no no maybe tomorrow come again
tomorrow okay I want to thank you then